- On this episode,
I scare someone and
I use my fake belt to consume an emotion.
(cars revving)
(hip-hop music)
♫ Hey ♫
- [Voiceover] Gary Vee.
(hip-hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them.
(hip-hop music)
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is Episode 115
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Jury duty continues so I'm out of studio.
By the way before you get into the show,
DRock you have to show
this billboard up here.
I don't know if you see this.
This really pisses me off.
I love these guys.
I know these guys.
I actually passed on
investing in their company,
in a mayonnaise company.
Big ups to you guys.
Congratulations. That's awesome to see.
Javits Center in the background.
DRock dropped his audio
thing. Go ahead, DRock.
Pick it up. It's okay.
We will look grey here for a second.
Super excited about the show.
Really fun impromptu
video yesterday that I did
that has caught some good
fire in the community.
So, if you haven't seen that DRock,
(snap) link that up.
I'm making this video
for the people that are
full of sh--, right?
The ones that tell me to my face everyday
that yeah (smack, smack).
And really want it and
don't recognize the actions
that it takes to get there.
And India, let's...
(car honks)
get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Javier asks,
(hip-hop music)
"As a rookie, how much
should I allocate to
"Facebook Dark Posts for
a Teespring Campaign?"
- Javier as a rookie,
which I like,
I guess a rookie entrepreneur,
I would allocate a
disproportionate amount of money
into Facebook Dark Posts
for Teespring Campaigns.
Especially if you make a
t-shirt that is very thematic
meaning,
if you made a t-shirt that was like,
"Denver Truck Drivers Rule,"
and then you dark post against people that
live in Denver that are truck
drivers as a profession,
you will crush.
And so, I think it's a
unbelievable platform
to convert on.
We've talked at nausea about this.
And as a matter of fact,
I'm even going to go completely
in a different direction.
I actually would challenge
most people watching
the show right now that
you should make a Teespring
and actually run a $100
worth of dark posts.
Go long tail with like,
"Teachers From St. Louis Rock,"
and learn the dynamics
of specific long tail,
surgical Facebook
advertising because I think
it will be successful.
- [Voiceover] Paul asks,
(hip-hop music)
"How do you 'diplomatically' tell the BOSS
"he's F'ing it up?!?!?!"
- Paul that's a good question.
I massively overvalue
the people in my company
who are comfortable enough in saying like,
"Hey, Gary, I don't
disagree with you now."
A lot of them walk into a
buzzsaw because they're wrong
and then they get clowned.
So you better make sure you're right about
the boss being wrong, right?
And so, but I think any great
boss will be super pumped
if you're willing to respectfully
point out things that
you massively disagree with.
And I think it's a win,
win situation for you
if you go down that route
because if you think about it,
if you give that feedback to the boss
and the boss...
agrees with you, maybe she or
he knew that you were right,
you've won points.
If they don't and they
completely disrespect you and
the others within the organization
that try to give feedback,
well then now you know you work for
a dipshit boss and you should
be looking for another job.
So to me there's really almost no risk
in going down the route of
giving critical feedback
to your boss.
Especially if you don't
love, love, love your job.
And more importantly,
it's an amazing proxy to
audit your boss which I
think is massively important
if you've decided to put your career into
the leadership of an individual.
Yeah let's just move
like, let's just move.
But actually yeah, let's
move this way 'cause
I like the way the people are walking.
- [Voiceover] Josh asks,
(hip-hop music)
"Which do you prefer
[abrasive vs. compassionate]
"when getting a point understood
to meet goals and why?"
- Josh, I'm curious why
you're asking this question.
I think it's maybe because you've realized
I'm abrasive and compassionate
at the same time.
And I'm very thankful that
I have a tool belt where
I pull out a lot of different emotions.
Competitiveness, caring,
warmth, sensitvity,
straight disrespect.
One of my favorites.
(click)
Such a deli--
that was me drinking self disrespect.
Such a delicious flavor.
Every situation calls for
a different concoction.
And so, what I spend
most of my time really
thinking about is getting to know
all the different employees
and trying to fig--
Did you like that Staphon
showed up in the back?
(trucks revving)
I'm over here.
Getting to know each and every employee
on an individual basis,
understanding the situation at hand,
and then being smart enough as the leader,
as the CEO,
to deploy the right mix, the
right blend at that moment
for the task at hand.
I actually have no emotion and no favorite
move.
No, I don't prefer
combativeness to compassion
to respect to any of this.
I really just whatever
I think at that moment
is the right move.
Sometimes I'll do six
months worth of compassion
and then straight karate chop,
sweep the leg to the mouth,
because clearly that wasn't working.
So, I'm adjusting in
real time to my clients,
to my employees, to my investors,
to my startups.
This is a never-ending,
constantly 24/7, 365.
Test and learn.
Use your intuition and not get romantic or
not get into a habit of
using one move over and over
because a funny thing
happens with these things.
It's kind of like medicine.
If you use it too often,
it stops working as well.
- [Voiceover] Raymond asks,
(hip-hop music)
"How do you think people will
consume news in the future
"and how can small publishers
like ourselves monetize
"on our content if it is
consumed on a native platform?"
- Raymond great question.
You're going to have to find
ways to integrate advertisers
in a way that if you're not
the platform where you're
monetizing the eyeballs,
well then you don't
deserve the dollars because
all the advertisers want
is the awareness, right?
I mean they're not smart
enough to recognize they want
the actually engagement
and the sell through.
Unfortunately right now they
still want the awareness.
So, if your news is
being consumed on Twitter
and not on your platform,
and there's no ad opportunity
for your advertisers
in that format and
that's going to Twitter,
well then you're fu----
and that's exactly what you
are alluding too.
I think what you need to do is A,
find ways to drive people to your world,
which is extremely difficult.
Or B, rethink the model all together.
Do you actually, you know,
when was it that media
and news companies decided
they were in the advertising business?
A long time ago.
But are you maybe in the events business?
Are you maybe in the consulting business?
Are you maybe in the
content production and
compete with VaynerMedia business?
Are you in the stand up comedy business?
I know that was weird,
but like that's really where I'm going.
You and everybody else selling
news has defaulted into,
"I sell advertising."
Why?
Why are you romantic about
the way you make your money?
Why are you using 80 years
of history to make your money
when the world is clearly
changing at a scale
that we've never seen?
Why?
Because innovation and innovators are rare
and far and few in between aren't they?
And so, I challenge you in this show,
at this moment,
and everybody else
trying to monetize news.
Recognizing news is now
being consumed on Facebook.
being consumed on Twitter.
You've lost your power of people
coming to your destination.
There's a couple of
ways to think about it.
Are you thinking about
virtual reality video?
Are you thinking about 3D printing?
Are you thinking about
mobile only society?
Are you thinking about the
next thing after mobile
which might be,
I can do it right here in thin air.
Or, more importantly,
'cause all of that stuff
is probably 10 years away.
Are you thinking about
different ways to make money?
Meaning, you have a news
outlet and because you're
good at producing news
and getting people to
consume it on the web,
maybe you help advertisers
get their content consumed
on Facebook and Twitter.
Rethink the game.
And by the way,
that was advice for everybody here.
Always rethink how you make your money.
Wine Library has a big
second floor right now
and I'm trying to sell it out as space
for events and things of that nature.
I'm making money on the real estate.
So rethink the way you make your money.
(car engines revving)
This great moment was brought to you by
the #AskGaryVee Show.
#AskGaryVee Show. Watch it.
(chuckling)
That was awesome.
That was a live commercial
of the show.
- [DRock] That was great.
- [Gary] You like that?
- Hey, Gary. It's Jim Mitchem.
I have a question about networking
for the creative class.
I'm a writer and I started
my own marketing consultancy
in January and I'm having
an issue getting out
and meeting people.
You meet a 100 people before breakfast.
Some of us don't have
that kind of personality.
So what advice would you
give people like me who
have a hard time getting
out, shaking hands,
and handing off business cards.
What can we do to help
grow our own companies?
You have anything?
- Jim that's a great question.
Networking doesn't come natural to--
give me my headphones, India.
Networking doesn't come
natural to everybody
and the truth is you've watched the show
probably enough to know I'm a big fan of
betting on your strengths versus
working on your weaknesses.
I believe people that are
more introverted, reserved,
it's hard for me to ra ra
you into going and like
shaking people's hands
and rolling up on people
and being like, "Hey."
Oh no, we're all great.
You know like that's not going
to be what you do, right?
That's not going to be what you do.
That's what I'd do,
but that's not what
you're going to be doing.
And so, I would say put out great content
and play the honey game.
Become the honey and
let the bees come to you
instead of you becoming
one of the bees, right?
And so, I think that's the game.
I think way too many
people are trying to be
better at things that seem obviously good.
And listen,
I spend a disproportionate
amount of time networking.
Much of which doesn't come to fruition.
So that could be a waste.
Maybe you're saving a lot
of time being a creative,
doing your thing.
So, I would say for you and
all the other people out there
that don't want to network,
hand out business cards,
shake hands, kiss babies,
scare red-headed dudes,
I think that you need to go
out and put out great stuff
and let people come to you.
Let your work speak for itself.
I would work in a B2B
Environment and try to get
your work seen in other
places except your blog.
That can be done behind your keyboard,
on email to blogs and
news sites that cover
the arena that you play in.
That would be my advice to you.
Let it come to you.
(car engines revving)
Cool.
Question of the day.
Oh I've got a good one.
Question of the day:
What are you 4th of July plans?
One of the things that
really matters to me
is getting to understand
all of you more and more
and more and more.
So, in detail, Vayner Nation,
what is your 4th of July plans?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(car engines revving)
Awesome. Did you capture
me scaring that guy?
Yeah, you got it?
- [India] Yeah, he was freaked out.
(inaudible)
- [Gary] It was good?
- [DRock] Yeah.